un père français a demandé à son pic
disant liberian que veux tu faire quand
tu seras grand palais le garçon lui a
répondu vivendi gran être une fille at
ça c'est une intrusion du pape dans dans
le débat a nommé le bas mais c'est le
pape est une autorité spirituelle
bon voilà
il a son appréciation et envoûtant
hésitant avoir des tendances
homosexuelles ou changer de sexe est une
chose mais faire un enseignement dans
les écoles sur cette ligne pour faire
changer les mentalités
c'est de la colonisation idéologique je
regrette cette parole pour le moins
légère et infondées je vois qu'il aura
été lui aussi victime de la campagne de
désinformation massive conduite par les
intégristes la fondation lejeune vigie
gène d'heure et d'autre part sa relève
voilà de l'intimé c'est vrai que exposés
les enfants à des livres qui peut être
rentrer de façon un peu trop cru dans un
certain nombre de sujets n'est peut-être
pas la meilleure solution voilà je le
dis je conseille au pape lors de l'un de
ses prochains déplacements en france de
venir à la rencontre des enseignants de
l'école française tout simplement et
puis discuter avec eux de feuilleter
lui-même ses manuels scolaires ses
programmes et de m'expliquer en quoi il
y aurait une théorie du genre qui
n'existent pas par ailleurs dans ses
livres les règles de la primaire à
gauche sont fixés et semble convaincre
un nouveau candidat s'est déclaré il
s'agit est d'arnaud montebourg et des
idées sont très simples sont celles la
dernière fois être placé dans le
primaire 5% du conseil national ou des
élus pour pouvoir se présenter
et puis
on devrait tourner aux alentours de 8 à
9000 bureaux de vote
quand la primaire de la gauche il y aura
votre ancien collègue donc françois de
rugy
c'est là la place d'écologistes naruto
non parce que l'écologie sortira aussi
congrue et sort et qu'elle l'est
aujourd'hui au gouvernement
l'objectif numéro 1 de montebourg c'est
de faire la peau de hollande
moi ça m'intéresse pas tous à son vieux
monde de paris sondage qui sort qui sort
aujourd'hui et qui donnent hollande à 48
% derrière montebourg à 52% pépère à ne
seraient plus des capsules et il serait
siphonné par pour la première fois lors
d'une élection présidentielle la liste
des parrains sera dévoilée en temps réel
sur le site du conseil constitutionnel
et le nom de chaque signataire sera
mentionnée pour les présidentielles
précédentes seuls 500 par un tirés au
sort et est divulgué une transparence à
l'extrême
décrié par les petits partis parce qu'il
ya une loi qui a été votée un peu en
catimini pour durcir les règles qui
permet de se présenter à l'élection
présidentielle on n'est pas dupe
pas dupe de la manoeuvre il la manière
dont ça a été fait vous savez dans tous
les camps il ya des gens qui de temps en
temps tu dise des choses intelligentes
même dans ma famille politique
ah c'est vrai mais pourtant vous ne
soutenez pas non mais non parce que 200
entendre